So step one.
For step one we need to take the product.
of a and its transpose
and then we do this again.
for a times the trans the transpose
of a
Why do you do this? Because once we have these two matrices who
will then be able to extract the eigenvalues, but
when we do extract the eigenvalues?
We need to take the square root. So step three.
We want to calculate the eigenvalues if
you like the single the singular values.
for
steps one and two
what's you have those singular values? We need to take the
square root of those angular of those singular values.
Once we have done this we have then we will
have then created the
Matrix S
And what about Matrix?
You and V transpose.
To calculate or to find this Matrix. We
need to orthogonalize.
this Matrix
and then orthogonalize that Matrix.
or the transpose
so this we will orthogonalize it and what is
orthogonized we all content one in a moment.
We need to orthogonize orthogonalize this to get
that Matrix.
And then orthogonalize this Matrix to get that
Matrix.
Now there are different algorithms for orthogonalization.
Okay, I'll tell you I'll describe to you
the problems of an orthogonal and orthonormal Matrix.
But there are different algorithms for orthogonalizing making
whatever this Matrix is.
The one we're going to look at is going to is called a
gram Schmidt.
algorithm
which is also supported by numpy and
even
well, not that algorithm specifically, I think the
ones numpy and Matlab support are
called a QR but these are both similar.
In what they do.
They both produce.
an orthogonal Matrix
now before let me just write down the steps.
And we'll do the same for step number six.
then once we have done this
Yeah, we would have been we had we would have had a produced
SVD.